u.s military command was silent about it
for years an airstrike that took the
lives of about 80 people mostly women
and children in the last days of the
syrian civil war and it's only thanks to
a new york times investigation that the
u.s military finally fessed up the exact
mixture of armed and unarmed personnel
could not be conclusively determined
likely a majority of those killed were
also combatants at the time of the
strike these two strikes were legitimate
self-defense strikes no disciplinary
actions were warranted ah we
investigated ourselves and decided there
will not be any punishments how
surprising for washington though it's a
lot like groundhog day the most recent
rerun was back in august when a drone
strike in kabul killed 10 civilians
including seven children the pentagon
initially said it didn't do anything
wrong after an internal investigation it
backtracked a bit but still said that
the soldiers involved were acting in
good faith they all had a genuine belief
based on the information they had in the
interpretations that that was a threat
to us forces an imminent threat to us
forces
that's a mistake it's a regrettable
mistake it's an honest mistake i
understand the consequences an honest
mistake i'm sure that will make the
relatives of the victims feel a lot
better
they say isis k lived in this house in
this house were these children members
of isis k a stupid thought without any
proof without any investigation they
attacked us and killed our children and
we will never forgive them
unfortunately the list of collateral
damage inflicted by us forces doesn't
stop there
[Music]
after so many accidents you'd think some
international body might try to
investigate at least one of them but
when the prime suspect seems to be
itching to impose sanctions on its
detractors is anyone surprised anymore
at the apparent lack of accountability
in instances like this you're never
going to have any accountability
anywhere
no one's going to take the take the heat
unless it's someone at the very lowest
levels who's going to challenge that
who's going to defy that
there's no higher authority to say no
wait a minute
this is crazy nothing's going to be done
it'll be another
case of uh justice not being rendered
and and life goes on and everyone will
forget about it except the immediate
families people didn't know where who
ordered the strike and there's
it allegedly
was done by a unit that isn't
accountable to anybody what kind of unit
is that the whole effort is to
try and downplay
these kinds of atrocities
and
because the united states of course is
uh
killing for democracy at all at all
times so uh
they think that they have this license
to kill in effect and that's the
unfortunate thing
you